[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم تستعيد جديد في الضفه
الغربيه بعد سقوطه ثلاثه شهداء وعشرات
الجرحى في اقتحامات نفذتها القوات
الاسرائيليه الاحتلال يقول ان مجنده اصيبت
في عمليه دهس بمستوطنه شرق رام الله وانه
قتل منفذها والخارجيه الفلسطينيه تطالب
المجتمع الدولي بتحمل مسؤوليته اساءه
تصاعد جرائم الاحتلال
القوات المواليه لموسكو تتهم كياب بنشر
جنود استعدادا لاقتحام المحطه النوويه في
زاباروجا السلطات الاوكرانيه تصدر تحذيرات
بشان غارات الروسيه في كل انحاء البلاد
وتطالب بامدادها بمنظمات دفاع جوي متطوره
قطر للطاقه توقع اول اتفاق طويل الامد مع
المانيا لتصدير الغاز المسال لمده 15 عاما
بدا من عام 2026 وزيره دوله لشؤون الطاقه
القطريه سعد الكعبي قال ان الاتفاق ياتي
ضمن مساعي برلين لتعويض النقص الناجم عن
تراجع امدادات الغاز الروسيه
بطوله كاس العالم قطر 2022 تدخل يومها
العاشر حيث تختت مباريات المجموعتين
الاولى والثانيه وتبدا الجوله الثالثه
والحاسمه من دوري المجموعات في كاس العالم
لحسم المتاهلين لدور ال16